Before we dive in, a quick heads up. If you're a qualified psychologist in private practice, then Dr Claire Plumley and I would love to invite you to our next in-person event. It's the psychologist Christmas Social, happening in Kingscross London on Saturday, the 6th of December 2025. It's your chance to connect with other brilliant minds, enjoy some festive food and feel part of a real community, especially if you're missing that work Christmas due feeling. Faces are limited and feeling fast, so if you or a colleague might be interested, you can find the link to grab your ticket in the show notes or in my bio on social media or just send me a DM. Dr Claire and I will look forward to seeing you there.
在深入探讨之前，先给大家提个醒。如果你是一位处于独立执业中的合资格心理学家，那么克莱尔·普拉姆利（Dr Claire Plumley）博士和我诚挚地邀请你参加我们的下一场线下活动。这是心理学家圣诞社交聚会，将于2025年12月6日星期六在伦敦国王十字区举行。这是一个与同行中的优秀大脑建立联系、享用节日美食并感受真正社区归属感的好机会，尤其是如果你因为节日期间的孤独感而错过了工作单位的圣诞聚餐。名额有限且正在快速减少，所以如果你或你的同事可能有兴趣，你可以在节目简介或我社交媒体的个人简介中找到获取门票的链接，或者直接给我发私信。克莱尔博士和我非常期待在那里见到你。
Baby loss is one of the most painful and silenced experiences a parent can face. If you've If you've clicked on this video, you're in the right place. In this episode, I'm joined by Dr. Kara Davy to talk about what baby loss really feels like. The grief, the silence and the moments that shape life forever. Together, we'll explore how parents can be supported and how compassion matters more than anything. I'm Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist, and I want this space to bring understanding and hope.
失去婴儿是父母可能面临的最痛苦、最常被噤声的经历之一。如果你点击了这期视频，说明你来对地方了。在本期节目中，我邀请到了卡拉·戴维（Dr. Kara Davy）博士，和大家聊聊失去婴儿到底是什么感觉。那种悲伤、那种沉默以及那些永远改变人生的时刻。我们将共同探讨如何给予父母支持，以及为什么同理心比什么都重要。我是玛丽安（Dr. Marianne）博士，一名合资格的临床心理学家，我希望这个空间能带去理解和希望。
And later in this conversation, we are going to be revealing what bereaved parents tell us they needed most but often didn't get. So stick around right to the end and if you find it useful please like, subscribe, comment and share. Hi, welcome along to the aspiring psychologist podcast. I am joined today by my guest Dr. Kara Davy who is a clinical psychologist. Hi Kara. Hi Marianne. Thanks for inviting me. I'm happy to see you. Nice to see you again so you have been a guest of the show before. We spoke about ADHD assessment didn't we? That's right we did. And today I just want to give a little bit of a trigger warning.
在稍后的对话中，我们将揭示那些经历丧子之痛的父母告诉我们他们最需要却往往没能得到的东西。所以请一直收看到最后，如果你觉得有用，请点赞、订阅、评论并分享。你好，欢迎收看《有志心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。今天和我一起做客的是我的嘉宾卡拉·戴维博士，她是一位临床心理学家。你好，卡拉。你好，玛丽安。谢谢邀请我。很高兴见到你。很高兴再次见到你，所以你以前也做过节目的嘉宾。我们聊过ADHD评估，对吧？没错，我们聊过。今天我只想给出一个小小的触发预警。
Obviously, we're going to be talking about baby and child loss. So if you are watching or listening to this and there's, maybe it's not the right time or if you've got younger or sensitive ears around you, please just be mindful of that, considering whether you need to listen now, whether you'll come back to it, whether you'll pop some AirPods or earphones in, so that just you, here's the content at this time.
很显然，我们要讨论的是婴儿和儿童的夭折。所以，如果你正在观看或收听这期节目，而现在可能不太是时候，或者你周围有年纪较小的孩子或比较敏感的耳朵，请务必注意这一点。考虑一下你现在是否需要听，是否以后再回头看，或者戴上AirPods或耳机，以便在这个时候只有你一个人听到这些内容。
Okay, this is a tricky area, Kara, It's an area you were already working in the area of trauma before you experienced your own very sad stillbirth of your daughter. But since then, you've really made it a clinical specialty because you realize that actually there's a bit of a lack of support for people that find themselves in this position. Well done for everything that you do and for creating such a compassionate, safe place for people. Can I ask what might feel like a controversial opener? Why does baby loss awareness matter? It matters because after someone loses a baby, it's one of the most difficult experiences they
好的，这是一个棘手的话题，卡拉。在你经历自己女儿不幸胎死腹中的悲剧之前，你其实就已经在创伤领域工作了。但自那以后，你真正将它变成了一个临床专业领域，因为你意识到，实际上对于陷入这种处境的人来说，支持还是有些匮乏的。为你所做的一切以及为人们创造这样一个富有同情心且安全的地方点赞。我可以问一个听起来可能有点争议的开场白吗？为什么婴儿夭折意识如此重要？这很重要，因为在一个人失去孩子之后，这是他们可能会经历的最困难的体验之一。
might ever have. And we, as society, as friends, as families, as colleagues, as, you know, someone near them can't undo that. We can't take away that, but what we can do is support them, and we can help them to feel understood. and validated and be with them and feel less isolated at such a difficult time in their life. And I think because it is such a sensitive topic on one that feels a bit taboo and one that we perhaps don't want other people
而作为社会、作为朋友、作为家人、作为同事，或者说作为他们身边的人，我们无法撤销这件事。我们无法消除这种痛苦，但我们能做的是支持他们，帮助他们感到被理解、被认可，陪伴着他们，让他们在人生如此艰难的时刻不那么感到孤立无援。我认为，正因为这是一个如此敏感的话题，一个感觉有点像禁忌的话题，一个我们或许不想让别人听到的话题，或者我们在措辞时非常小心，这就意味着有时候人们不仅要经历丧失本身以及丧失带来的所有影响，而且在丧失之后还会感到极度的孤立。他们可能会觉得实际上人们——我经常听到人们说，你知道的，人们过马路绕开我，不跟我说话，因为他们觉得有点尴尬，担心自己说错话，或者说，雇主曾建议
to hear about or we're very careful how we say, it means that sometimes people can experience not only the loss and all the implications of the loss, but they can feel a lot of isolation after their loss. They can feel like actually people, you know, I hear frequently, people say, you know, people cross the road to not talk to me because they feel a bit awkward because they're worried about saying the wrong things or, you know, employers have advised
员工（团队成员）在有人经历丧失后不要与其联系，然后他们会觉得，这些认识了很久的同事甚至在如此艰难的时刻都没有确认我是否还好。所以我觉得，如果我们不提高对这个话题、对它所带来的影响以及如何提供最佳支持的认识，那么实际发生的情况是，人们会变得越来越孤立，这会加剧他们的痛苦。因此，赋予人们理解和支持的能力真的非常、非常重要。而根据我失去父亲的经历，我觉得当时我的一些同事被告知——我几乎就像是——“别，玛丽安，别因为任何事联系她。”但我觉得作为一个团队成员，说这样的话其实是可以的：
people, you know, the team not to get in contact after someone's had a loss and then they feel like, these are colleagues have known for a really long time who aren't even checking I'm okay at, you know, such a difficult time. So I think if we don't raise awareness of the topic and the impact and how to best support it, then actually what happens is people end up more and more isolated and that compounds their distress. So it's really, really important to empower people to be able to understand and support. And I think my experiences of having lost my dad is that I think some of my colleagues at the time were said, were told and I'm almost like, don't, don't worry Marian, don't contact her about anything. But I think as a team member, it's okay to kind of say,
“我们要持续多久？他们是不是明确要求过永远不要联系，永远不要提及此事？还是说，其实某个时候去支持这个人是可以的？”所以这可能就像——就像你在尽量不激起波澜，尽量尊重人们的意愿。但作为经历过这件事的人，作为专家和母亲，我相信你会说，你并不是指永远，对吧？是的，绝对如此。而且我认为，不断给某人发信息，或者在他们可能正处于例如丧假期间时发送与工作相关的事宜，这两者是有区别的。而且这取决于某人的丧失发生在什么时候，来决定他们是否有权请假。
well, how long for, have they specifically asked not to be contacted ever, not to have this mentioned, or actually, you know, is there a time where actually it's okay to support that person? So maybe it's like it's like you're trying not to rock the boat and you're trying to honour people's wishes. But the person who's had this happen, I'm sure you would say as an expert and as a mother, you didn't mean forever, you know? Yeah, absolutely. And I think there's a difference between continually messaging someone or messaging someone about work-related issues when they might be on, say, bereavement leave, for example. And it will depend when someone's losses as to whether they're entitled to leave.
是的，这与发一条短信说，“我注意到你没来上班”或“我听说了你的遭遇，我非常难过，你不需要回复，我只是想让你知道我在想着你”，这两者有着本质的区别。不，我想任何经历过丧亲之痛的人，无论是失去孩子还是其他，都不会因为一条写着“我在想着你”且没有任何回复压力的信息而被冒犯。
Yeah, there's a real difference between that and sending a text saying, you know, I've noticed you're not in work or I've heard about your loss. I'm so sorry. You know, there's no need to reply. I just wanted to let you know I'm thinking of you. No, I don't think anyone who's been bereaved, whether that's of a child or not, would take offence to a message that says, I'm thinking of you with no pressure to respond.
这真的是个绝佳的观点。事实上，经理们的意思可能是“请不要就电子表格联系卡拉”，“请不要催问她为什么还没提交X、Y、Z、她的工时表、她的差旅里程”。他们并不是指“不要支持她”、“不要做个人”。但也许有些传达的信息可以稍微明确一点。或者，就做一个好人。如果你平时会给他们发短信说：“我在看电视节目，你在看吗？”如果你有那种友谊，那么，你知道的，正如你所说，说一句“听说你正在经历的事情，你所经历的一切，我感到非常遗憾。如果你准备好了，我随时都在”，我觉得这绝对是可以的。绝对的。这非常、非常重要。你知道的，这会带来巨大的改变。而且，
That is such a good point. And actually what the managers maybe mean is please don't contact Kara about the spreadsheet. Please don't chase her for why she hasn't submitted X, Y, Z, her time sheet, her mileage. They don't mean don't support her. Don't be a human. But maybe some of the messaging maybe could do with firming up a little bit. Or just be a good person. If you would usually text them to say, I'm watching something on TV. Are you watching it? If you've got that kind of friendship, then, you know, I think it's absolutely okay, like you say, to say, I am so sorry to hear what you're going through, what you've been through. I'm here, if and when you're ready. Absolutely. And that's so, so important. You know, it makes a huge difference. And, you know,
而且我认为你在那里提出了一个非常重要的观点：如果你平时会给某人发短信，那就不要改变这种行为。因为我经常听到人们说，朋友们试图表现得敏感，他们在没有我的情况下聚会，因为他们不想这会勾起我的伤心事或者其他什么，所以我被排除了。或者他们本可以聊聊电视节目的日常对话，他们却会想：“哦，也许我不会提那个节目，以防有什么困难的内容，或者他们现在不想听到这个，”而不是去向对方确认：“你最近怎么样？我一直在想这个，”或者“我们在安排这个聚会，这可能会勾起伤心事，我理解这种想法，你想来吗？因为如果你觉得不会太勉强的话，我们很希望能见到你。”所以，心里一直装着对方，这非常、非常重要，对我们所有人来说在任何时候都是如此，婴儿夭折也没有什么不同。然而，正因为这感觉像是一个禁忌和敏感的主题，这种情况——人们感到孤立和被冷落——确实经常发生。
and I think you raise a really important point there about if you would normally text someone, don't change that behaviour, because I hear that so often where people will say, you know, friends are trying to be sensitive, they're meeting up without me. because they don't want it to be triggering for me or whatever else so they're excluded or you know general conversation that might have about TV they're like oh maybe I won't mention that program in case there's you know something difficult or they don't want to hear about that now or rather than actually checking out with someone you know how are you doing I was thinking about this or you know we're arranging
是的，好的，所以基本上尽量不要去审查或压制你最初的冲动或最初的想法。你知道，“噢，我要去某某地方——卡拉一定会喜欢来的。噢，不行，因为这个那个原因我不能邀请卡拉”——也许无论如何都要联系卡拉，你知道的？是的，绝对的，除非你知道——除非那个人明确说过：“我想退出这个朋友的WhatsApp群聊，例如，因为我觉得这让我触景伤情。”或者，如果他们选择退出那个群聊，当然要尊重他们的意愿。不要说：“噢，让我们把他们加回来吧，因为他们可能会喜欢这个对话。”但是，是的，我觉得保持作为人的本质、保持联系、让某人知道你在想着他们，这非常重要，除非他们明确表示：“我此时需要一点空间。”举个我自己的例子，我有一个非常要好的朋友，在我经历丧失一年后——你知道的，丧失后的周年纪念日通常对人们来说非常艰难——在我经历丧失一年后，她即将迎来另一个
this meetup it could be triggering I understand that thought would you like to come because we'd love to see you if it doesn't feel too much or so there's something really really important about being held in mind, you know, for all of us at all times, and it's no different with baby loss, and yet because it feels such a taboo and sensitive subject, actually that is something that, you know, happens a lot, is that people feel isolated and left alone. Yeah, okay, so almost try not to police or censor your original impulse or original thought, you know, oh, I'm going so-and-so-carra would love to come, oh, no, I can't invite Kara because of because of that like maybe reach out to carra anyway you know yeah absolutely unless you know
孩子，性别和我失去的那个孩子一样。这挺触景伤情的，也挺不容易的。她一直不断地联系我。我告诉她：“你能给我一周时间吗？就在你刚生完孩子、正好是周年纪念日的这一周，我需要一点点空间，因为我觉得这真的很难熬。”几乎感觉这挺触景伤情的，我想对她来说也是如此，而她却不断地联系我。请务必尊重这一点。作为一个朋友，我向你保证，我会重新和你联系的，这并不是永远的，我只是需要一点点空间。所以我想，如果有一个非常具体的例子，我认为，请听进去，因为这很难。但，是的，在其他时候，你知道的——我又恢复了联系，之后一切就又……还可以了。
unless that person has specifically said you know i want to come out of this friend's WhatsApp group for example because i'm finding it i'm finding it triggering or you know if they choose to come out of that group then of course honor honor that you know don't go oh let's add them back in just because they might like this conversation or um but yeah i think there's something really important about remaining human and remaining in contact and letting someone know you think of them unless they are specifically saying, I need a bit of space at this point. So as an example, I had a really close friend who a year after my loss, which, you know, the kind of anniversary is typically very difficult for people after a loss. And a year after she was due with another
但是，是的，我认为如果有非常明确的例子表明有人在对你倾诉，倾听是很重要的。但在其他情况下，人们确实希望被挂念，确实希望——是的，被包容，哪怕这很困难，或者至少拥有表达自己是否愿意出席、是否希望被记挂和包容的机会。是的，谢谢你。我觉得这真的很有帮助。而且，真正认识到如果你作为经历丧失的父母自己也在苦苦挣扎，那么
baby, same gender as a baby, I'd lost. It was quite triggering. It was quite difficult. And she kept reaching out to me. And I said to her, can you just give me a week? Like this week where you've just given birth and is the anniversary. I just need a little bit of space because I'm finding this really difficult. And it was almost like that was quite triggering. I think for her and she'd keep reaching out to me. Please just honour it. Like as a friend, I promise I will be back in contact with you. This isn't forever. I just need a little bit of space. So I think if there's a very specific example, I think, you know, listen to that because it's hard. But yeah, other times, you know, And I was back in contact and it was, you know, okay again afterwards.
发声争取是没问题的。说出你认为此刻对你最有帮助的事情是没问题的，无论是需要更多、更少的联系，还是完全不同的事情，对吗？是的，而且我认为许多经历过丧亲之痛的父母会觉得这相当困难。我不愿做太多的假设，比如性别假设，但我支持的许多失去婴儿的女性会说，她们天生相当讨人喜欢（讨好型人格）。她们觉得很难大声说出来为自己争取。我认为经历丧失后最难的一点不仅在于你要试图应对丧失本身，而且因为人们不理解——通常人们不知道该如何反应，或者担心做错事——这意味着经历过丧亲之痛的父母
But yeah, I think if there's a real clear example where someone's telling you, it's important to listen. But otherwise, people do want to be held in mind. They do want to, yeah, be included, even if it's difficult or at least have the opportunity to say, you know, whether or not they want to be there and want to be thought of and included. Yeah, thank you. I think that's really helpful. And to actually know that if you are struggling as a loss parent yourself, that it's
如果觉得自己有能力为自己发声，如果能够说出“其实，这对我有很大帮助”或者“其实我觉得那很触景伤情”，如果能更好地表达自己的感受和需求，他们往往能得到更好的支持和照顾。但实际上，这依赖于对自己的情绪有很好的认知、能够沟通这些情绪，并且身边有能够倾听这些情绪的人。而实际上，这很难。所以，是的，许多女性会说：“其实，现在并不是我觉得自己有足够的力量为自己发声的时候。”然而，如果不去发声，那些触景伤情的事情，或者由于其他人不知道而无法改变行为的情况，就会持续发生。或者，如果人们在圣诞卡片上没有写上婴儿的名字——例如，我经常说，如果你在用社交媒体，很多人会因为触景伤情而退出，也许只需分享一条动态说：“我希望在卡片上写上宝宝的名字，”因为这能让人们知道是什么情况。但这随后就得依赖于当事人，而他们在悲伤、经历了丧失的时候，往往会想：“为什么我要做这个？”这是可以理解的。而且，是的，在这个时候去发声是一件很难的事。
okay to advocate. It's okay to say actually what you think would be helpful for you right now, whether that's more, less contact, or something completely different, you know? Yeah, and I think a lot of brave parents find this quite difficult. I think I don't want to make too many assumptions, kind of gender assumptions, but a lot of women I support who've lost a baby will say that they are naturally quite people pleasing. They find it quite hard to speak up to advocate for themselves. And I think what can be really difficult after a loss is not only are you trying to manage the loss, but because people don't understand, you know, often people don't understand how to respond or are worried about doing the wrong thing, it means that brief parents
是的，是的。在这方面其实我是从你身上学到的——你知道的，你是我的朋友，我们一起悲伤，我觉得悲伤时有个伴感觉挺好的。我不知道如果没有你，我怎么熬过那段时光。所以谢谢你，作为朋友，也作为——你知道的——受过专业培训、能够支持我、基本上还能做我朋友的心理专业人士。你知道的，你在卡片上写名字这件事上提醒过我，所以，是的，我认识的那些经历过悲伤的人，如果且当我寄生日卡或圣诞卡时，我仍然会试着提及他们的名字。事实上，有人回复我说：“你是唯一一个这么做的人，我真的很喜欢这样。”所以，这就像——就像传递那些智慧的宝石一样。因此，任何收听或观看的人，也许你可以成为那个——你知道的——人们期待收到信件的人，
often get better support and care if they feel able to advocate for themselves, if they're able to say, actually, this is really helpful for me, or actually I find that quite triggering, or the more someone is able to kind of articulate how they feel and what they need, often the better they are supported by others. But actually, that relies on a good ability to know your emotions, to be able to communicate them, and, you know, to have people around who listen to those emotions. And actually, that's hard. And so, yeah, many women are like, actually, this isn't a time where I feel strong enough to advocate for myself. And yet without advocating, often the things that are triggering or continuing to be triggering with other people not having an opportunity to be able to change
因为这能让他们感到被认可、被看见，让他们觉得自己的痛苦并没有——你知道的——被完全敷衍和忽视。是的，这真的很重要。首先，我想说的是，有个人陪在身边至关重要，我们一起经历悲伤——虽然我们俩经历丧失都让人感到悲伤，但你给予了极大的支持，在那段时期对我意义重大。我想这也是我热衷于
that behaviour because they don't know or you know if people are not including a baby's name in a Christmas card for example i often say if you're on social media and many people will come off because it's triggering maybe just share a post that says i'd love to have baby's name included in the card because it lets people know what what it is but it then relies on that person and they're often like why am i doing this when i'm when i'm grieving and i've you know experienced a loss which is understandable and yeah it's a hard time to be advocating yeah yeah and I learned from you in that regard actually so you know you are my friend and we grieved together and grief is kind of nice to have a companion in I think I
支持他人的部分原因，我很幸运有你和其他几位真正理解我、真正看见我、真正支持我的人。这为我的心路历程和应对能力带来了巨大的改变。这就是为什么我如此热切地希望，如果其他人没有这样的条件——其实我不知道如果没有这些，我该如何应对。我真的希望其他人也能有那种——你知道的——体验。所以，是的，我会永远心存感激，我认为这确实产生了真正、真正的深远影响。所以，是的。接下来关于卡片，是的。我的意思是，这不仅仅是“我看见了你，我承认这段时间对你来说可能很艰难”，尤其是当有人失去了一个婴儿或一个孩子时——你知道的，那个孩子不再过着他们的人生了。而且，这是一种承认“你很重要，你存在过，而且，你知道的，在这个世界上人们依然在想着你”的方式。这非常、非常重要，因为很多人因为害怕让别人心烦而不这么做，尽管经历丧失的父母无论如何都不会忘记他们的孩子。不过，是的，这真的很重要。
don't know how I'd have got through that time without you say thank you as a friend and also as a you know someone that's empathic and trained to to kind of support me but also be my friend basically and you know you told me at about names and cards and so yeah people I know that have grieved I still try to if and when I do send birthday cards or Christmas cards I still try to mention their name and actually people have come back to me and say you're the only person that does that and I actually really like that so it's like it's like just passing on those those gems of wisdom so anyone listening or watching maybe you could be someone that you know people look forward to receiving correspondence from
而且，从心理学的角度来看，有一个概念叫“持续纽带”（continuing bonds）。我认为人们通常会觉得，你走出了悲伤，就会把某人淡忘并继续前行，或者那是更偏向传统的老派悲伤观念。但我们现在知道事实并非如此。对于那些应对和管理得更好的人来说，通常是因为他们找到了将那个人留在生命中同行的办法。对经历丧失的父母来说，这可能意味着他们有一个代表孩子的泰迪熊。这可能意味着他们有印有孩子名字的东西，旁边可能放着一些物品，
because it makes them feel validated and seen and like their suffering isn't, you know, being just completely gossed over and overlooked. Yeah, that's really important. And firstly, just to say, absolutely, the importance of having someone there and, you know, the fact that we grieved together, you know, it was obviously sad for both of us
或者……在卡片上看到一个孩子的名字意义重大。这是你能做的事情之一，它传达的是：“我记得，我记得你，你很重要。”是的，绝对的。而且我认为，我作为临床医生、做过几百次甚至可能几千次评估的经验是，当我们筛查某人的心理健康
that we were experiencing loss, but you were so supportive and meant so much to me at that time. And I think that's part of my passion. for supporting people is I was lucky enough to have you and a few others who really got it and really saw me and really supported me. And it made such a difference to my journey and my ability to cope. It's why I'm so passionate that if other people haven't got that, like actually I don't know how I would have cope without that. And I really want other people
并思考问题爆发的根源时，有时我会处于非常荣幸的地位，听到人们向我倾诉流产、晚期流产或死产的经历。这可能发生在10年、20年、30年、40年或50年之后。当然，随着产科服务环境的改变，以及我们现在处理悲伤和丧失的方式、我们在社会上谈论这一话题方式的改变，
to be able to have that, you know, that experience. So yeah, I'll be forever grateful and I think that, you know, has had a real, real influence. So yeah. And then in terms of the cards, yeah. I mean, it's not just, I see you, and I acknowledge that this might be a difficult time for you, but especially in the example, you know, when someone has lost a baby or a child, you know, that child is not living their life anymore. And, you know, it's a way of acknowledging that you were important. You existed and, you know, you're, you're continuing to be thought of in the world, which is really, really important because many people don't do that for fear of upsetting someone when brief parents don't forget their children anyway but yeah it's really important and
我认为牢记这样一种想法非常重要：人们可能经历过完全不同的遭遇。他们可能从未见过自己的孩子。他们可能没有留下任何照片。他们甚至可能经历过——你知道的——为了免除你的痛苦，所有东西都被收拾干净、清理带走。但我的经验是，那种经历只会停留在
you know from a psychological perspective there's something called continuing bonds and i think often people think you get over grief and you kind of forget about someone and move on or that was the more kind of traditional old school way of thinking of brief and we know that's not the case now and for people who cope and manage better often it's because they've found ways of holding that person in their life with them and that might be for brief parents you know it might be they have a teddy bear that represents their child. It might be they have things with their child's name on, and might have things on the side,
一个没有人去看、没有人去确认的巨大伤口。当然，我们是在分阶段疗愈的。但如果你从未获得过帮助来疗愈这一点，那么尽管已经过去了许多许多年，这仍然可能相当生涩。甚至随着我们现在在媒体上的讨论方式、在特殊的纪念日等场合看到烛光
or but seeing a child's name in a card means a lot. It's one of the things you can do that says, you know, I remember, I remember you and you're important. Yeah, absolutely. And I think that my experience is of having been a clinician and doing, I'm probably going to say hundreds, maybe thousands of assessments, is that when we're screening someone's mental health
点燃，这些都可能会深深唤起人们的回忆。这或许是人们第一次觉得这样做是安全的，去处理这一切。因此，有时候这可能会让人感觉非常、非常贴近现实，但人们有时会对这种感受进行一定程度的否定，对吧？是的，绝对的。我是苏塞克斯郡一家名为“奥斯卡心愿基金会”（Oscar's Wish Foundation）的婴儿夭折慈善机构的理事。我和他们一起做过很多活动，
and kind of thinking about the onset of problems, sometimes I've been in the very privileged position where I've been told about miscarriages or late miscarriages, stillborn babies. And it might be 10, 20, 30, 40, 50 years later. And of course, with the changing landscape of maternity services and of the way that we kind of deal with grief and loss now and the way we talk about that in society,
我在经历丧失后也做了很多筹款活动。通常在筹款活动中，你会发现，特别是如果那是更公开的活动，可能会有人来参加，他们可能在50年前经历过丧失，或者是……他们看到了标志，看到了支持。通常，你知道的，你能看出这有多么生涩、多么艰难，或者他们会停下来，花时间说：“我只希望——我只希望这种理解、这种支持以及这种在悲伤过程中被鼓励与你的宝宝在一起的方式，在当时——在那个时候——就已经存在并被理解了。”所以，绝对的，你是对的。痛苦并没有消失，
I think it's really important to hold on to the idea that people might have had a different experience. They might have never seen their baby. They might have not had any photos. They might have almost been, you know, had things tidied up and cleaned up and taken away to save you that pain. But my experience was that that just kind of stays
仅仅因为某人没有见到他们的宝宝，或者被鼓励“向前看”或“不要去想它”，它就依然存在且依然生涩。所以，正如我们刚才所说，如果你——如果你因为担心提及某人的宝宝而会惹他们难过——这不是说痛苦会消失，它依然存在，在任何时刻都与他们同在。你不会惹他们难过，你是给了他们一个思考和表达自己感受的机会，而不是把这些都憋在心里。是的，绝对的。
as this kind of gaping wound that nobody's looking at and nobody's validating. And so we heal in stages, of course we do. But if you've never had help to have that heal, then this could still be quite raw, despite it being years and years later. And even with the way we talk in the media now and seeing the lighting of the candle
我只是在想，由于播客和YouTube内容的长期性质，人们可能会在各个阶段接触到这些内容，而且可能有人正处于刚刚失去亲人的阶段。我们能否简单回顾一些非常基础的“该做什么”，比如如果你失去了婴儿或儿童，然后你回到了家？
at special memorial days and things, that might really evoke things for people. For the first time, it might feel safe to do that and to process all that. And so it might feel, at times very, very close, to the service but people can kind of invalidate that a bit sometimes I think can't they yeah absolutely so I'm a trustee for a baby loss a Sussex based charity baby loss charity called oscar's wish foundation I've done lots of events with
比如，在实际操作中该怎么做？如果宝宝处于需要办丧事的阶段，你如何开始考虑安排葬礼？如何处理这些实际的事情？如果这一切都是计划外且突如其来的，你如何安排请假？卡拉，你能带我们稍微了解一下吗？是的，我觉得有必要承认，从某种程度上讲，这是一个很难回答的问题，因为这很大程度上取决于
them and I did lots of fundraising after my loss and often at fundraising events you might find especially if they're more public events you might find someone comes along who maybe had a loss 50 years ago or and they see the sign they see the support and often, you know, you can see how raw and difficult it is, or they will stop and, you know, kind of take their time to say, I just wish, I just wish that this understanding and this support and this way of being able to be encouraged to be with your baby as part of the grief process, you know, was around and was understood, you know, back back then. And so absolutely, you're right. The pain doesn't go away, you know, just because someone doesn't meet their baby or,
丧失的具体情况，比如丧失发生在多早的阶段，这决定了某人有权享受多少假期，他们是否要举行仪式，他们是否选择为宝宝举办葬礼，他们是否有丧亲助产士，以及有些丧亲助产士提供什么样的服务。很多医院都有丧亲助产士。有些会为人们安排葬礼，并在那方面提供很多帮助；另一些则留给他们自己去处理，或者是人们自己选择这样做。所以具体情况差异相当大。我的网站上有一系列为人们准备的免费资源。其中一份是关于如何支持同事、朋友或家庭成员的。还有一份是为最近经历丧亲之痛的人准备的，关于这些第一步，比如考虑也许你
you know is is encouraged to kind of move on or not think about it it's very much still there and still raw so you know if you're as we've said earlier if you're if you're kind of worried about mentioning someone's baby because you might upset them like it's it's not a case of it goes away it's still it's still there and with them at all points and you're not going to upset them you're going to give them an opportunity to think about and express how they feel and rather than kind of just holding that in yeah absolutely And I guess I was just kind of thinking about the fact that because of the kind of long-term nature of podcasts and kind of YouTube content is that people might be coming to this at all stages, and it might be someone's very recent in their loss. Can we just go over some very basic kind of what-to-dos, like if you have lost a baby or a child and then you're sort of home?
刚刚得知消息，甚至还没分娩，你究竟该如何应对这下一步？任何人通过剖腹产来生下一个已经去世的宝宝都是非常罕见的，因为没有医学上的需求，所以通常人们必须经历分娩的过程。因此上面有一些提示，能帮助应对这些情况的实用建议，以及如何应对这种丧失的方法。里面有很多不同的内容，取决于所处阶段、人们想要参与的程度以及具体情况。有些人可能是在分娩后失去了宝宝，是的，情况也确实大不相同。所以网站上有一份指南，涵盖了许多这类事情。但如果你有更
Like, what do you do practically? How do you begin to think about arranging funerals if kind of baby was at a stage where that needs to happen? Like, how do you do these practical things? How do you arrange time off with work if this is all planned and not as expected? Could you guide us through that a little bit, Cara? Yeah, I think it's worth acknowledging. In a way, this is a really hard question to answer because it will depend on. a lot on the circumstance of the loss, so how early the loss was in terms of how entitled
具体的问题，我很乐意回答。不过我觉得针对不同的情况有太多不同的答案，这使得很难给出一个直接的回答。谢谢你。这是一个非常有帮助、非常有帮助的回答。我想象着，实际上，还有额外的创伤——我有过两次剖腹产经历，两次都是紧急剖腹产，但我能想象自然分娩的经历，可能伴随着任何会阴伤口，或者下体感觉非常不舒服，而且宫缩本身会让你的腹部在之后的几天和几周内变得非常、非常敏感。我真的在想
someone is to leave, whether or not they're having a service, whether they choose to have a funeral for their baby, whether they have a bereavement midwife, so some, and what service that bereavement midwife offers. So a lot of hospitals that have a bereavement midwife. Some will arrange funerals for people and will kind of really help with that side of things, others it's left for, it's left for them to do, or people choose to do. So the circumstance advances vary quite a lot. I do have, on my website, there's a series of free resources for people. There's one about supporting colleagues or supporting friends or family members. There is one for people who are recently bereaved about these kind of first steps, like thinking about maybe you've
那些刚刚分娩，但随后必须照顾自己的身体、却没有任何活着的、能在家里陪伴身旁的宝宝需要照顾的人的经历。我想这真的很艰难，对吧？真的很难。是的，绝对的。对很多人来说，他们的身体会成为触发点。许多人觉得自己被身体背叛了，看到自己的身体可能会让他们很有感触。产后肿胀或恢复自然需要时间。当人们试图在身体恢复期间四处走动时，可能会被误认为——人们在没有看到宝宝的情况下，会假设他们一定还在怀孕。所以，是的，这其中有很多状况。同样，在那份免费指南中，也有关于如何应对和照顾身体的信息，因为经历丧失的父母可能会发现照顾自己的身体很困难，甚至会倾向于想要忽视它，因为他们觉得身体背叛了他们，或者因为他们感到愤怒。
just found out and you haven't even given birth yet, like how on earth do you approach this next step? It's very unusual for anybody to have a C-section to give birth to a baby when they found out that they've passed because there's no medical kind of need for that and so generally people have to go through the process of giving birth so there is tips on there things that might kind of help with that there's things that help with practicalities how to cope with that loss so there's lots of different things in there depending on the stage and how involved people want to be and the circumstances some people might have lost a baby after birth and yeah again the circumstances really do change. So there is a guide on there that approaches lots of those things. But if you have a more
我确实和一家名为mutu的公司合作过一篇博客，mutu系统是关于产后恢复的。对我来说，尽力照顾自己的身体非常重要，我知道在身体上照顾自己、为身体做好准备、不让盆底健康受到长期影响，会有助于我的情绪健康。所以对我来说，我做了这些。但上面有一篇关于此的博客，其中包含了更多关于你与身体的关系以及如何照顾身体的信息。
specific question, I'm happy to answer it. But I feel like there's lots of different answers for lots of different circumstances that makes that really difficult to give a straight answer. Thank you. And that's a really helpful, a really helpful answer. So, and I think I was really imagining, actually, the additional trauma. So I've had two cesarean sections for, you know, two babies, two emergency sections, but I was imagining the experience of having birthed naturally and maybe any kind of perineal wounds or kind of just very uncomfortable kind of, you know, downstairs areas and the contractions themselves can leave your belly very, very tender for days and weeks afterwards. And I sort of was really thinking about the experience of
我想甚至——当我的宝宝夭折时，我联系全科医生（GP）进行产后六周检查，他们查看了我的病历，然后说：“哦，我看到宝宝没有存活，因此没有必要进行六周检查。”我当时想：“好吧，难道没有人会——我分娩了，难道我不需要检查一下我的身体恢复得怎么样吗？”所以我觉得，甚至经常会有其他人这种不屑一顾的态度，认为“有这种期待，只要继续过日子就行了”。你仍然需要疗愈，你仍然需要照顾自己，人们往往不会像对待家里有一个活着的宝宝的新父母那样，期待你能好好休息。所以我觉得思考这一点非常重要——
of someone who's recently given birth, but then has to care for their body but has no baby to care for that's living, that's with them at home. And I think it's really hard, isn't it? Really hard. Yeah, absolutely. And for a lot of people, their body is triggering. Lots of people feel like their body has let them down and they can feel quite triggered by the sight of their own body. It takes time, obviously, for swelling or to recover postnatally. People can be mislellanated. People can be mistaken as they're walking around are still pregnant when they're kind of trying to recover because people assume without a baby that they must still be pregnant. So yeah, there's a lot around. And again, in that free guide, there is information about trying to cope and care for your
是的，与身体的关系，以及其他人可能会做出的假设，或者人们可能不会去想、但作为经历丧失的父母却至关重要的那些事情。这也是我创建免费指南并在医院里放置它、供人们在医院阅读的原因之一。其中还包括制作纪念品之类的内容，比如如何与宝宝共同创造回忆，如何制作许多人在离开医院后会说“我真希望我当时做过”的那些东西——我真希望我给宝宝做了手脚模，我真希望我为了做项链留下了指纹，或者诸如此类关于如何创造这些回忆的事情，或者如果人们想要照片的话。所以有时候我们不会去想这些事情。因此，非常重要的是，要向人们提供关于在早期阶段了解什么可能会对长期恢复有帮助的信息，哪怕这些事情在短期内感觉很难接受。是的，绝对的。我很高兴这是一个现在获得了更多支持的领域。
body because there can be, brief parents can find it hard to care for their body and can kind of almost be inclined to want to neglect it because they feel that it's let them down or because they feel angry or um i did do a blog with someone called mutu which is a mootu system is like a trying to recover postnatally about for me it was really important to try and take care of my body and to that i knew it would help my emotional well-being to physically take care of myself and to prepare my body and to not feel kind of impacted in terms of pelvic health long term by it so for me i kind of did that but there is a blog about that and there is more information your relationship with your body and how to take care of it.
而且我认为，甚至只要知道“丧亲助产士”这个术语——如果你出于某种原因没有被分配到一位，而且你失去宝宝或不得不生下宝宝的时间还不算太久，仅仅知道这个术语就能赋予你力量，让你知道该要求什么。或者，如果收听节目的观众本身就是心理健康专业人士，我们在工作中会听到各种各样的情况，对吧？这会赋予我们力量去思考：“哦，实际上，我不知道我是否可以与这个人分享这些信息，无论是为了他们自己的利益，还是为了他们向我提及的某人，这样我们就能真正践行将会我们所知分享给需要之人的咨询模式。”是的，如果你是一名在 perinatal（围产期）服务中工作但并不专攻此领域的心理健康专业人士——在某些服务中、在某些地区，围产期团队也提供丧失支持；在某些地区，有一个单独的团队；而在某些地区，可悲的是，这项服务根本还没有推广开来。但如果你是一个较少从事丧失工作的围产期团队，因为那不在你的职责范围内，
And I think even, you know, when I had my loss, I contacted the GP for the kind of six week check and they kind of checked down my notes and they went, well, I can see that baby didn't survive, therefore there's no need for a six week check. And I was like, well, is anyone gonna, I've given birth, like do I need to be checked to see how I am physically or so I think there's even
我认为在考虑支持那些曾有丧失经历、可能再次怀孕的个人的心理健康时——即经历丧失后再次怀孕的阶段——牢记以下几点非常重要：可能会触发人们的事物、可能存在的想法和感受、可能有所帮助的实际步骤，你知道的，你可以将他们转诊到的地方。在考虑迎接丧失后的又一个宝宝以及它带给他们的所有感受时，实际的步骤比如生育计划，在经历丧失后一切都大不相同。有时候我和经历丧失的父母交谈时，他们会觉得服务机构可能会忽视这一点——在他们考虑下一次怀孕时，对先前丧失的真实影响视而不见。这几乎就像是“让我们只考虑这次怀孕吧”，而没有考虑到先前的背景。因此，我认为作为心理健康专业人士，
that kind of dismissal often by other people of like you know this expectation to just get on with things it's so you still need to heal you still need to take care of yourself and people don't expect you just to kind of rest often in the same way that you would if you were a new parent with a with a baby here live so i think it's really important to think about that yeah the relationship to the body and the assumptions that maybe other people might make or you know kind of things people wouldn't think about that are really important as a very parent and that's one of the reasons I created the free guide and I've put it in hospitals for people to look at in
牢记先前丧失的影响确实很重要。是的，你知道的，我认为我最喜欢的书之一就是贝塞尔·范德科克（Bessel van der Kolk）写的《身体从未忘记》（The Body Keeps the Score）。是的，就像——哪怕只是试图让自己、让身体进入分娩姿势，都可能是极度、极度容易触发情绪或充满情感波动的。有些人发现这能帮助他们感觉更贴近失去的宝宝，但也许你会有各种各样的感受，也许会有某种程度的安慰，但也伴随着大量、大量的痛苦，以及对新宝宝的期望和对他们健康的担忧交织在一起的种种情绪，所有的感受都有，对吧？是的，绝对的，这是一种真正的混合体。所以有一个针对丧失后再次怀孕的词叫“彩虹宝宝”。有些人喜欢这个词，而有些经历丧失的父母非常不喜欢。我想有些人不喜欢这个词的原因，是因为他们认为这代表人们淡化了过去。
hospital and it includes also things like memory making like what how are you how to make memories with your baby how to create some of those things that a lot of people will say they leave hospital and I wish I wish I'd done you know a cast with my baby I wish I'd done fingerprints for a necklace or so some of those things around how can you make those memories or if people want photos so I think sometimes we don't think about these things. So it's really important that people are kind of given information around what might be helpful to know in these early stages that will help longer term recovery, even if they feel hard in the short term. Yeah, absolutely. I am pleased that this is an area that's got more support
这几乎就像是“瞧，雨后天晴”，仿佛你失去的宝宝就像是雨和不好的事情，而这个是好的事情，这淡化了之前的经历。但对我来说，当我想到彩虹时，我认为这两者是共存的——曾经有过悲伤和难过，你知道的，作为失去宝宝经历的一部分；然而，你失去的宝宝不仅是雨，同样，接下来——
around it now. And I think even knowing that term bereavement midwife, you know, if for some reason you haven't been given one and it's kind of quite recent that you've lost a baby or that you've had to give birth to a baby, just knowing that term can kind of empower you to know what to ask for or if people are listening to this because they are actually mental health professionals. You know, we hear all sorts, don't we, in our work? It kind of just empowers us to think, oh, actually, I wonder if I could share this information with this person either for their own benefit or for someone that they're telling me about so that we are really doing that consultation model of sharing what we know
围绕着它。我想，哪怕只是知道“丧亲助产士”这个词，你知道的，如果由于某种原因你没有分到这样的专业人员，而且你失去孩子或不得不产下孩子的时间并不久，单单知道这个词就能赋予你力量，让你知道该要求什么，或者如果有人听这个节目是因为他们本身就是心理健康专业人员。你知道的，我们在工作中会听到各种各样的情况，对吧？它会赋予我们力量，让我们想到，哦，事实上，我不知道我是否可以与这个人分享这些信息，无论是为了他们自己的利益，还是为了他们向我提起的人，这样我们就能真正做到分享我们所知的咨询模式
to the people that need to know it. Yeah, and if you're a mental health professional working in perinatal services who don't specialize, so in some services, in some areas perinatal teams also support with loss. In some areas, there's a separate team, and some areas, sadly, it hasn't been rolled out at all yet. But if you're a perinatal team who does less of the loss work, because that isn't kind of within your remit I think it's important when you're thinking about supporting people's mental health who've had previous losses and might be pregnant again that kind of pregnancy after loss stage to bear in
把它传递给需要知道的人。是的，如果你是一名在围产期服务中工作但不是专门从事这项工作的心理健康专业人员，也就是说，在某些服务中、在某些地区，围产期团队也支持应对失去孩子的家庭。在某些地区，有一个单独的团队，而在另一些地区，遗憾的是，这项服务根本还没有推广开来。但是，如果你是一个较少从事丧亲相关工作的围产期团队，因为那不在你的职责范围内，我认为当你考虑支持那些曾经失去过孩子、可能再次怀孕的人的心理健康时——也就是那种失而复得后的怀孕阶段——你必须牢记
mind the things that might be triggering for people the thoughts and feelings that might be there the practical steps that might be helpful you know the places you might be able to refer them in thinking about welcoming that you know, another baby after loss and all the things it's brought up for them. But, you know, practical things like birth planning, you know, kind of it's all very different after a loss. And I think sometimes I speak with brief parents who feel that it can be missed by services, like the real impact of the loss when they're thinking about the next pregnancy. It's almost like it's let's just think about this pregnancy without bearing in mind that
脑海中要记住可能会触发人们情绪的事物、可能存在的想法和感受、可能有所帮助的实际步骤，你知道的，你可以把他们转介过去的机构，考虑到迎接一个你知道的、在失去孩子之后的另一个宝宝，以及它为他们带来的所有感受。但是，你知道的，像分娩计划这样的实际事情，你知道的，在失去孩子之后，这一切都非常不同。而且我认为有时我与丧亲父母交谈时，他们觉得这些可能会被服务机构忽视，比如当他们考虑下一次怀孕时，失去亲人的真正影响。这几乎就像是，让我们只考虑这次怀孕，而没有考虑到
previous context. So I do think it's important, yeah, as mental health professionals. for us to bear in mind that the impacts of that earlier loss too. Yeah, and, you know, I think one of my favourite books of all time is The Body Holds the Score by Bessel van der Kalk and, yeah, like just even trying to get yourself, your body into birthing positions might be incredibly, incredibly triggering or emotive. Some people find that it helps them to feel closer to baby that they've lost, but maybe you feel all the things, maybe there's some element of comfort, but also lots and lots of distress and kind of lots of feelings about hopes for the new baby and worries about kind of
之前的背景。所以我的确认为，是的，作为心理健康专业人员，我们必须牢记早期丧亲所带来的影响。是的，你知道的，我认为我历来最喜欢的书之一就是贝塞尔·范德科克写的《身体会记住》（The Body Keeps the Score），而且，是的，就像仅仅试图让你的身体进入分娩姿势都可能会非常、非常具有触发性或引发强烈的情感。有些人发现这有助于他们感觉离他们失去的孩子更近，但也许你会感受到各种各样的情绪，也许有一点安慰的成分，但也有许许多多痛苦，以及对新宝宝的期望和担忧等各种感受
about their health like it's all the things isn't it yeah absolutely it's it's a real mixture so there is a term for pregnancy after loss of a rainbow baby and some people like that term and some very parents really don't and I think some people the reason they don't like the term is because they see it as people kind of dismissing the past they're almost like oh here's the sunshine after the rain as if your bereaved baby is the kind of rain and the bad thing almost and this is good but it dismisses the experiences but for me when I think of rainbow I think of the two existing together so there has been sadness and upset you know kind of as part of the loss of your baby but you know your bereaved baby is not just the rain but likewise that next
关于他们的健康——这真是百感交集，对吧？是的，绝对的，这真的是一种混合的情感。因此，对于失去孩子后再次怀孕，有一个术语叫“彩虹宝宝”，有些人喜欢这个词，而有些丧亲父母真的很讨厌它。我想有些人不喜欢这个词的原因是，他们认为这代表人们在抹去过去，他们感觉就像是，哦，雨后见晴，好像你失去的宝宝就是那种雨、那种不好的事一样，而这个宝宝是好的，但这抹去了过去的经历。但对彩虹这个词，我想到的是两者共存——也就是说，会有悲伤和难过，你知道的，作为你失去宝宝经历的一部分，但是，你知道的，你失去的宝宝不只是雨，同样地，接下来的那个宝宝也并非如此
step of trying again if someone is in that stage they it's not that they don't feel any good emotions not like they're not looking forward to being a parent or they're not excited about that stage but alongside that they are also experiencing all of the difficult emotions so the rainbow is the kind of two existing together and i think if we're if we're thinking about the most important thing you can do to support someone as a you know who's bereaved as being empathic and supportive and ensuring they feel seen acknowledging both of those emotions is so important you know i run free support groups for people who've lost a baby and also for people for people in that next step of kind of trying again or pregnancy again after loss and the most
尝试再次怀孕的阶段中，如果一个人正处于这个阶段，并不是说他们感受不到任何美好的情绪，也不是说他们不期待成为父母，或者对这个阶段不感到兴奋，但在伴随这些情绪的同时，他们也在经历所有艰难的情绪。所以彩虹（指彩虹宝宝）可以说是这两种情绪同时存在。我想，如果我们考虑到支持某人最重要的事情，你知道的，作为一个经历丧亲之痛的人，要具有同理心和支持性，并确保他们感到被看见，承认这两种情绪是如此重要。你知道的，我为失去孩子的父母开设了免费支持小组，也为那些处于再次尝试怀孕或失后再次怀孕阶段的人开设了小组，而最常见的
common topic I would say in that group is around just people being wholeheartedly excited for them after a loss but without any acknowledgement of actually all the other emotions that they're suddenly now feeling guilty that they're not thinking about their other baby as much or what that means about their first baby or they're also feeling that you know their body is physically from a trauma point of view back in the time before you know it's back pregnant which is the state it was when they had their loss and they're now terrified or you know all of the other emotions that exist alongside it that not being seen is so difficult and so many people in the kind of pregnancy after loss groups will say i just need to people to acknowledge that you know congratulations
主题，我想在那个小组里，就是人们在失后对他们全心全意地感到兴奋，但却没有对他们突然间感到的所有其他情绪有任何承认——他们会因为没有更多地去想他们另一个孩子而感到内疚，或者这对于他们的第一个孩子意味着什么，或者他们还觉得，你知道的，从创伤的角度来看，他们的身体在物理上回到了过去，你知道的，回到了怀孕状态，也就是他们经历丧失时的状态，而他们现在感到恐慌，或者你知道的，所有其他与之并存的情绪没有被看见是如此艰难，因此失后怀孕小组中的许多人会说，我只是需要人们承认，你知道的，恭喜
and i imagine this is a really tough time are you okay or you know just just that simple both and rather than kind of assuming one replaces the other makes such a difference. Yeah, so I guess because this is a psychology podcast, we're thinking about these things not being mutually exclusive and by that I mean we haven't just got two train tracks that never meet. We've got actually I'm really excited and delighted about giving birth to this baby who is with us and alive and healthy. I'm also still really sad about this one who didn't have the same outcomes and it's okay to check in with both of those things because of course what we know is that they converge and they can both exist it's not either or yeah absolutely and for a lot of people
并且我能想象这是一段非常艰难的时期，你还好吗，或者你知道的，仅仅是那种简单的“两者兼顾”而不是那种假设一种情绪取代另一种情绪的做法，会带来如此大的改变。是的，所以我想因为这是一个心理学播客，我们在思考这些事情并不是互不排斥的，我的意思是，我们不仅仅有两条永远不会相交的火车轨道。实际上我们有：我为生下这个与我们在一起、活着且健康的宝宝感到非常兴奋和高兴。同时我也为那个没有得到同样结果的孩子感到非常难过，去正视这两种感受是没问题的，因为当然我们知道它们会交汇，它们可以共存，这不是非此即彼的。是的，绝对的，对于许多人来说
there's a real sadness as well of the impacts that their loss has had on them as a person from a trauma perspective in you know kind of yeah just how they feel but also feel that it's robbed them of actually this pregnancy is no longer, you know, exciting in the same way. Like suddenly now I'm triggered by things. Actually, the support I would have had at pregnancy yoga or whatever actually now feels quite difficult. Also, for a lot of people, you know, there's sadness not just around my baby's not here and will never get to live this life. You know, I may be welcoming another baby, but, you know, there's also sadness around the interaction. I won't get to see the sibling interaction but there's also a kind of this experience is completely different to my
从创伤的角度来看，他们的失落对他们作为一个人所产生的影响也带来了一种真正的悲伤，你知道的，不仅仅是他们的感受，还觉得这剥夺了他们原本的快乐——实际上这次怀孕不再像以前那样令人兴奋了。就好像突然之间我被各种事情触动了。实际上，我在孕期瑜伽或其他活动中本应得到的支持，现在实际上感觉相当困难。此外，对于许多人来说，你知道的，不仅有围绕着“我的宝宝不在了，永远无法体验这种生活”的悲伤。你知道的，我可能会迎来另一个宝宝，但是，你知道的，围绕着这种互动的悲伤也是存在的，我将无法看到手足之间的互动，而且还有一种体验与我
last pregnancy in terms of i'm now you know feeling so many difficult emotions alongside the sad alongside you know kind of joy and excitement or gratitude so yeah absolutely yeah it's it's lots of that innocence i think for me is that i just didn't know how awful this could be and i was way more fun before 2017 kara i think we can both agree Like I just, I don't know, it's just, I was just different, you know. Yeah, it takes, it means life just becomes more serious. And, you know, everything feels a bit heavier and a bit more like, you know, there's just a lot of extra.
上一次怀孕完全不同，因为我现在，你知道的，在感受到悲伤、快乐、兴奋或感激的同时，也感受到了许多艰难的情绪，所以是的，绝对是这样的，是的，这其中包含了很多那种纯真，我想对我来说就是我简直不知道这会有多糟糕，在2017年卡拉之前我有趣得多，我想我们都可以同意这一点。就像我只是，我不知道，就是这样，我只是变得不一样了，你知道的。是的，这需要，这意味着生活变得更加严肃了。而且，你知道的，一切感觉都有点沉重，而且更像是有很多额外的负担。
Just to say, you're still very fun, by the way. But yes, there is a, you know, it does shift and change people. And absolutely, people talk a lot about having to reconstruct who they are. and, you know, that loss of innocence is absolutely huge. I remember, you know, I felt, feel I coped fairly well in my pregnancy after loss despite it being difficult, but I will never quite forget the shock
顺便说一句，你还是很有趣的。但是是的，确实有一种，你知道的，这确实会转变和改变人们。而且绝对地，人们经常谈论不得不重新构建他们是谁，你知道的，那种纯真的丧失绝对是巨大的。我记得，你知道的，我觉得在经历困难的情况下，我在失后怀孕期间应对得相当不错，但我永远不会忘记那种震惊，
of walking into a pregnancy yoga class that I'd done, you know, in my previous birth and my baby I'd lost and with the previous baby I was lucky to have here, you know, kind of safe. But I walked in, and the innocence of people in the check-in at the beginning were like, oh, I can't wait to be pushing my baby in a pram. And, you know, like all of the kind of naive, I've never, never even a thought that anything could go wrong, would go wrong, or, you know, just a pure excitement and joy and a state that I just couldn't quite connect with anymore, but remembering that I had. And it just really triggered me. And I think it was one of the most triggering points of my pregnancy. And I left the room and was like, well, I was not expecting that. Like it hit me like a ton of bricks. And it was that innocence that I was just like, oh, I do remember having that innocence. It was like a clear kind of view of how I had been versus how I was now and what a brick wall there was
当我走进一个孕期瑜伽班时——那是我在之前的生育中做过的，而我失去了那个宝宝，在另一个我有幸留在这里的宝宝身上，你知道的，感觉是安全的。但我走进去，那些人在开始签到时的纯真表现就像是，哦，我已经迫不及待地想推着我的婴儿车了。而且，你知道的，就像所有那种幼稚的想法——从来、从来没有想过任何事情会出问题，会出错，或者，你知道的，只是一种纯粹的兴奋和快乐，而那是我再也无法完全产生共鸣的状态，但我记得我曾经有过。这真的触发了我。我认为这是我孕期中最具触发性的时刻之一。我走出了房间，心想，我可没料到会这样。这就像一砖头砸在我身上。正是那种纯真让我觉得，哦，我确实记得拥有过那种纯真。这就像是对我过去的样子与现在的样子的清晰对比，以及它们之间存在着多么厚重的一堵墙，
between them and how I could never almost go back to that. Yeah, I think there's a really powerful song by Kat Stevens that was covered by Boyzone as well actually. And it's father and son and it's, you know, the lyrics are something like, you're still young, it's not your fault. And whilst this isn't about age, we're not talking about the age of an expectant mother, it's almost like you just don't know what it is that you don't know. And that's not your fault, but I just will need to just hold in mind the fact that I know that it's not all sunshine and rainbows and not everyone has this experience. But yeah, it's not invalidating yourself for having those ragey thoughts and feelings. Like you know stuff that they don't know and you've been
而我几乎再也无法回到过去了。是的，我认为卡特·史蒂文斯有一首非常震撼的歌，后来也被Boyzone翻唱过，实际上。那是《父亲与儿子》，你知道的，歌词大概是这样的：你还年轻，这不是你的错。虽然这不是关于年龄，我们谈论的不是准妈妈的年龄，但这几乎就像是你只是不知道你所不知道的是什么。这不是你的错，但我只是需要把这样一件事记在心里：我知道这并不全是阳光和彩虹，并不是每个人都有这种经历。但是，是的，不要因为你有那些充满愤怒的想法和感觉而否定自己。就像你知道他们不知道的事情，而你经历过
through experiences that maybe they haven't, they haven't been through. Yeah. And I don't, I mean, some people do feel rage about it and as you know there is a normality in that so there's absolutely no judgment i don't think i felt rage i just felt an utter sadness of you know kind of yeah just the kind of this is the this is the impact and this is how i can never quite go back really like the analogy of kinsu of the you know the japanese art of putting something back together so if you imagine a kind of vase on the side it gets knocked over it's smashed you're never going to be able to put those pieces back together and it looks like a vase that has never been smashed. And yet you can put the pieces together and spend time putting gold between it, putting glitter on it, making it look good but in a different way.
他们可能没有经历过的经历。是的。而且我并不是说——我的意思是，有些人确实对此感到愤怒，正如你所知道的那样，这其中有一种正常性，所以绝对没有评判。我想我并没有感到愤怒，我只是感到一种彻底的悲伤，你知道的，关于那种，是的，就是这种影响，以及我如何再也无法真正回去了。我真的很喜欢金继（Kintsugi）的比喻，也就是日本人把东西重新拼凑起来的艺术。如果你想象桌子边上有一个花瓶，它被碰倒了，碎了，你永远不可能把那些碎片拼回去，让它看起来就像一个从未碎过的花瓶。然而你可以把碎片拼凑起来，花时间在缝隙里填上金粉，撒上亮片，让它以一种不同的方式看起来很好。
And, you know, and I think that's the process lots of brief parents will talk about after their loss is they have to put themselves and their kind of personality and their experiences back together. and there's often a period of kind of resistance of I want to be the person I was like I'm upset that I might now be triggered by these things or I might feel angry or upset or and lots of people trying to be who they were and I think often you know we have to get to a point or it's really helpful if we can get to a point of actually maybe I'm not the same as I was but there's ways in which I'm probably actually more empathic more supportive and you know kind of there's positive things that have come from being able to cope with this. loss rather than the loss itself and then there's other ways in which those cracks might always be there and it's really important to be able to shift to that perspective but to acknowledge that the cracks still exist because that's where people feeling validated if we don't acknowledge that yeah and i think that even crops up in between kind of relationships doesn't it so not all people are expecting a baby with a partner but often that is that is the norms still that people are. And even our different views within a relationship can be further wounds
并且，你知道的，我认为这是许多失独父母在失去孩子后会谈到的过程，他们必须将自己、他们的性格和他们的经历重新拼凑起来。而且通常会有一段抵抗的时期，比如“我想成为以前那个我”，我很难过我现在可能会被这些事情触动，或者我可能会感到愤怒或难过，很多人试图做回以前的自己。我想通常，你知道的，我们必须达到一个点，或者如果我们能达到这样一个点会真的很有帮助：其实我可能已经不再是以前那个我了，但在某些方面，我可能实际上更有同理心，更具支持性，你知道的，从能够应对这种失落中产生了一些积极的事情，而不是失落本身带来的。然后还有其他方式，那些裂痕可能永远存在，能够转变成这种视角真的很重要，但同时要承认裂痕依然存在，因为如果我们不承认这一点，人们就会觉得自己没有被认可。是的，我认为这甚至会出现在各种关系之间，不是吗？
in this kind of broken pot. And sometimes people are able to work through those. Sometimes it feels hard to work through that trauma and that becomes a relationship trauma and ultimately decisions about long-term futures. This is a big deal. It affects all aspects of life, doesn't it, Cara? Yeah, absolutely. And I think that's something. thing, you know, when we're talking about raising awareness of baby loss, I think that's the thing here is that we're not just talking about, and it's big in itself, losing the baby, losing all the hopes and dreams in the future, but it is a fundamental shift in every aspect of people's lives. You know, people move jobs, they move houses, they, you know, people, some people really
因此，并不是所有人都是和伴侣一起期待一个宝宝，但通常这仍然是人们的常态。甚至我们在一段关系中的不同观点，也可能在这个破裂的罐子里造成进一步的创伤。有时人们能够克服这些困难。有时感觉很难克服这种创伤，这就会变成一种关系创伤，并最终决定长期的未来。这是一件大事。它影响了生活的方方面面，不是吗，卡拉？是的，绝对是的。我认为这就是那件事，你知道的，当我们谈论提高对婴儿夭折的认识时，我认为这里的重点是，我们不只是在讨论——这本身就是一件大事——失去婴儿，失去所有的希望和未来梦想，但它是人们生活方方面面的根本转变。你知道的，人们换工作，搬家，你知道的，有些人真的
have to move, whether that's for different services because they're triggered in their home, It's every aspect of life, their personality, as you say, relationships, you know, for lots of people, these are real relational traumas, you know, when you're experiencing something so difficult, you know, often you look to the people close to you to support you and to help you. And, you know, in the experience of having lost a baby, both partners are grieving. And can they be there and support each other in that grief? Or do they actually need very different things? You know, we often see one partner might really want to talk. about it all the time and need to kind of try and, you know, kind of really process how they're feeling all of the time. And that might feel really difficult for the other partner and they need to avoid and not talk about it and not think about it. And then you can get the relational trauma of I told them I couldn't talk about it and they keep talking about it or, you know, vice versa. I told them I really need to talk and they weren't there for me. And further down the line when people have survived and coped in whatever way they need to, they look back at the relationship
不得不搬家，无论是为了不同的医疗服务，因为他们在家里被触动。生活的方方面面，他们的性格，正如你所说，还有关系。你知道的，对许多人来说，这些都是真正的关系创伤，你知道的，当你经历如此困难的事情时，你知道的，通常你会指望身边亲近的人来支持你和帮助你。而且，你知道的，在失去孩子的经历中，双方伴侣都在悲伤。他们能在这种悲伤中陪伴并支持彼此吗？还是他们实际上需要非常不同的东西？你知道的，我们经常看到一个伴侣可能非常想一直谈论它，需要尝试，你知道的，真正去消化他们一直在感受的情绪。而这对于另一个伴侣来说可能会觉得非常困难，他们需要逃避、不谈论它、不去想它。然后你就会得到关系创伤：“我告诉过他们我不能谈论这个，但他们一直在说”，或者，你知道的，反过来。“我告诉过他们我真的很需要倾诉，但他们没有在我身边。”在未来的某个时刻，当人们以他们需要的任何方式生存下来并应对过去时，他们会回过头来看这段关系，
and go, but I really needed you and you weren't there. Or, you know, so for something, people it is a real you know kind of turning point in their relationship and yeah it really does impact every area of life in a way that I think sometimes we can we can miss as professionals if if we haven't had the experiences ourselves or or know someone who have or you know had the relevant training absolutely and that's why this podcast is just gold isn't it I think because we can't know what we don't know but we can we can do our best to be curious and to learn carra we did mentioned rainbows. We did mention rainbow babies. Could you tell us about your book that's got rainbow baby in the title, please? Yeah, so I wrote a book called, there's a rainbow baby in my
然后说：“但我真的很需要你，而你不在。”或者，你知道的，对某些人来说，这确实是一个，你知道的，他们关系的转折点。是的，它确实影响了生活的每一个领域，以至于有时作为专业人士，如果我们自己没有过这些经历，或者不认识有这样经历的人，或者没有接受过相关的培训，我们有时会忽略这一点。绝对是的，这就是为什么这个播客简直是金矿，不是吗？我认为，因为我们无法知道我们所不知道的，但我们可以尽最大努力保持好奇心并去学习。卡拉，我们确实提到了彩虹。我们确实提到了彩虹宝宝。你能跟我们讲讲你的那本书吗，书名里有“彩虹宝宝”，好吗？好的，我写了一本名为《我
mummy's tummy. And I guess that was my experiences. As I mentioned, I'm unfortunate to have had a child before. My loss is here safely, and he was three at the time of a loss. And when I fell pregnant again after my loss I spent lots of time talking to him about I had to pick the right time to tell him I guess it's a whole other another another topic but essentially the book is my experiences of what I found helpful in preparing him for another baby coming because often when children have experienced loss they can be quite black and white like why would you try again when the last baby died or they can make quite kind of difficult kind of comments and I think many bereaved parents if they have another child here worry about how to talk to them how to
妈妈肚子里有一个彩虹宝宝》的书。我想那是我的经历。正如我所提到的，我很幸运在之前有一个孩子安全地留在这里，在我经历失落时他三岁。当我失后再次怀孕时，我花了很多时间跟他谈论——我必须选择合适的时间告诉他，我想这又是另一个话题了——但基本上这本书是我的经历，关于我发现什么对帮他为另一个宝宝的到来做准备是有帮助的。因为通常当孩子们经历过失落时，他们的思维会非常非黑即白：既然上一个宝宝死掉了，你为什么还要再试一次？或者他们会发表一些相当难懂的评论。我认为许多失独父母如果他们这里还有另一个孩子，会担心如何跟他们谈论，如何
support them when to tell them when they're pregnant again what to tell them about it you know how to speak to them about it and they when bereaved parents are pregnant again and they're feeling so nervous about will my baby arrive here safely this time it can feel really hard to reassure a child of what's been done differently this time. and how, you know, how there's lots of things in place to try and minimize that. And parents are like, well, do I guarantee it because I've got no guarantees or do I tell them how nervous I am? So the book is all about helping brief parents to be able to support children in pregnancy after loss. And also there's a kind of Q&A at the back of just how do we
支持他们，什么时候告诉他们再次怀孕了，什么时候告诉他们这件事，你知道的，如何跟他们谈论这件事。当失独父母再次怀孕并且对“这次我的宝宝能安全到达这里吗”感到非常紧张时，要向孩子保证这次有什么不同，以及有很多事情在试图将风险降到最低，这会让人感觉很难。父母们会想，我是该打包票，因为我根本没有保证，还是该告诉他们我有多紧张？所以这本书旨在帮助失独父母在失后怀孕期间支持孩子。而且在书的背面还有一个问答环节，讲述我们如何进行一些艰难的对话，以及分享什么和不分享什么来支持孩子完成这段旅程。
have some of these difficult conversations and what to share and whatnot to share to support children in that journey. But it's actually a book to read to your child, isn't it? But there's useful stuff at the back for the parent themselves as well. Yeah. So it's a children's, yeah, you're right. It's a children's book. It's illustrated for children. It talks them through the journey. What we know for children is that often they will find it easier if it is somebody else's experiences that are similar than, you know, about themselves. So, you know, if you were doing EMDR therapy with a child, you would talk about, you know, you'd write a story for them of the event that happened about another little boy or girl that it happened to,
但这实际上是一本读给孩子听的书，对吧？不过书的背面也有对父母自己很有用的内容。是的。所以它是一本儿童书，是的，你说得对。这是一本儿童书。它是为儿童配图的。它引导他们走过这段旅程。我们对儿童的了解是，如果那是别人的类似经历，而不是他们自己的经历，他们通常会觉得更容易接受。所以，如果你对一个孩子进行EMDR治疗，你会谈论，你知道的，你会为他们写一个关于发生在另一个小男孩或小女孩身上的事件的故事，
or so this is a chance for them to read about somebody else in a similar situation that might kind of validate how they might feel, but it also might help them to understand and then it helps the parents to have, you know, to answer any questions that might come up as a result of that. Yeah, absolutely. And just before we finish, could you tell us about your free baby loss support groups, which I just, you've done them for so many years and I just want to say, well done and thank you because I know they're an incredibly valuable resource, but Tell us about them, Kara. Thank you.
或者，这是一个让他们了解处于类似情况的别人的机会，这可能会验证他们的感受，但也可能帮助他们理解，然后这有助于父母回答因该情况而产生的任何问题。是的，绝对的。就在我们结束之前，能跟我们讲讲你的免费婴儿夭折支持小组吗？我只想说，你已经做了很多年，我只想说，做得好，谢谢你，因为我知道它们是非常宝贵的资源，但给我们讲讲它们吧，卡拉。谢谢。
Yeah, so the support group started in COVID five years ago now. And that's because the baby loss charity that I'm a trustee for, they offer counselling support and they were all furloughed during the pandemic. So I started running support groups for them just to support bereaved parents or people who were pregnant again because it was such a difficult time and it was so hard to kind of get support. And then one-to-one clients that had at the time were like, oh, can I join it?
好的，所以支持小组是在五年前的新冠疫情期间开始的。这是因为我担任信托人的婴儿丧失慈善机构提供咨询支持，而在大流行期间他们都被强制休假了。所以我开始为他们运营支持小组，只是为了支持失独父母或再次怀孕的人，因为那是一个非常艰难的时期，而且很难获得支持。然后我当时的一些一对一客户说，“哦，我能加入吗？
It would be really helpful to kind of connect. So now they're open to anybody, regardless of where you are. They are monthly groups. They run on Zoom so that you can, you know, attend wherever. And they are an hour each month, the first Sunday of each month. And it's a space to be with other people who understand who get it. And yeah, it's a safe space for. people who don't have that safe space or for people who would benefit for more, you know,
进行交流会真的很有帮助。”所以现在它们对任何人开放，无论你在哪里。它们是每月一次的小组。它们在Zoom上运行，这样你无论在哪里都可以参加。它们每个月一个小时，在每个月的第一个星期日。这是一个与其他理解、懂你的人共处空间。是的，这是一个安全的空间，为那些没有这样一个安全空间的人，或者为那些能从更多，你知道的，更多支持中受益的人提供。
more support. So yeah, they run every month. There are a number of different free resources available on my website. If you go onto there, but if you scroll down on the page, you can see and you can join, just type in your email address and you will get monthly reminders just with the Zoom links so that you can kind of attend the groups and obviously you can unsubscribe at any point should you not want to. But yeah, it's just a way of connecting people. really nice some of the clients I've spoken to years down the line and say I'm still in contact with so-and-so who I met on the group or you know it's really nice that people become a support outside of the group as well so amazing and whilst you
所以，是的，它们每个月都运行。我的网站上提供许多不同的免费资源。如果你去那里，但在页面向下滚动，你可以看到并且你可以加入，只需输入你的电子邮件地址，你就会得到每月提醒，其中带有Zoom链接，这样你就可以参加小组了，当然如果你不想参加了，随时可以取消订阅。但是，是的，这只是一种连接人们的方式。真的很好，我有些客户多年后交谈时说：“我仍然和在小组里认识的某某保持联系”，或者，你知道的，人们在小组之外也成为了一种支持，这真的很棒。太棒了。虽然你
often specialise in in person stuff in Sussex these groups are open to anybody aren't they yeah absolutely we are open to anyone and there's you know within the practice we also offer so I support people personally I have many other psychologists in the practice who also support people who specialize in this, you know, type of support. And again, we do do remote support as well. It's for anyone who wants to be supported by someone who really gets it and understands the area. And I don't want geography to be a limiting factor on that. Amazing. Well done. And if people want to follow you on Instagram or somewhere like that, what's the best handle for them to look for? So the handle is always in my heart.
通常专攻萨塞克斯郡的线下事务，但这些小组对任何人开放，不是吗？是的，绝对的，我们对任何人开放。并且你知道的，在诊所里我们也提供，所以我个人支持人们，诊所里我还有很多其他心理学家，他们也支持专门从事这种支持的人。同样，我们也提供远程支持。这适合任何希望得到真正懂它、理解这个领域的人支持的人。我不想让地理位置成为这方面的限制因素。太棒了。做得好。如果人们想在Instagram或其他地方关注你，他们最好找哪个账号？所以账号总是always in my heart。
Perfect. Thank you so much for your time, Kara. and I will see you soon. Take care. Thank you. Thank you so much to my guest and to my friend, Dr. Kara Davy. It's always an absolute pleasure to speak with her, and I hope you found this content to be helpful. You might well be watching because you, yourself, are experiencing a loss or have experienced a loss,
太完美了。非常感谢你抽出时间，卡拉。我们很快再见。保重。谢谢。非常感谢我的嘉宾和我的朋友，卡拉·戴维博士。与她交谈总是绝对的荣幸，我希望你发现这些内容很有帮助。你可能正在收看，因为你自己正在经历失落或曾经经历过失落，
or you might be your friend, family member, or even working with someone in a mental health capacity or physical health capacity who is, experiencing this or has experienced this. I would love to know whether you have found this content helpful. Please do drop a comment, a like that can be done on Spotify or on YouTube. And if you'd like to learn more about Kara, her story and what happened to her and her little girl, you can do in my book The Grief Collective Stories of Life, Loss and Learning to Heal. She is from page 190. And there's lots of real
或者你可能是某个朋友、家庭成员，甚至是以心理健康或身体健康身份与正在经历或经历过这一过程的人共事的人。我很想知道你是否觉得这些内容有帮助。请发表评论、点赞，这可以在Spotify或YouTube上完成。如果你想了解更多关于卡拉、她的故事以及她和她的女儿身上发生了什么，你可以在我的书《悲伤集体：生活、失落与学会治愈的故事》中找到。她在第190页。那里有很多因为各种原因而感到悲伤的人们的现实
life reflections of people who have grieved for a variety of reason. I hope that you are being supported, you're being validated, and you're supporting and validating yourself too. Such important things to do. Please do look after yourself. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. With this podcast, that's your side. You'll be your side. Your way to being qualified It's the aspiring psychologist podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent My name's Yana
生活反思。我希望你得到了支持，你的感受得到了认可，并且你也在支持和认可自己。这些都是非常重要的事情。请务必照顾好自己。如果你想成为一名心理学家，就让这成为你的指南。有这个播客在你身边。它会伴你左右。你通往合格之路，这就是《有志心理学家播客》，我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。我的名字叫雅娜，
and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me of confidence that no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist. I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是一名心理健康实习从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。达到这个目标竟然有这么多不同的途径，这让我感到惊讶，而且成为一名临床心理学家并没有完美的途径。这让我充满了信心，觉得自己并没有做错，并减轻了自己的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会把书放下了。这一集还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。